-Lauren London, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
Thank you for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
-This is your first
ever late night talk show.
-It really is, yes.
-I'm excited.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hopefully not my last.
-No.
It's definitely not your last.
-I'm kind of nervous.
-No, don't be nervous.
-Okay, okay.
-I want to talk about the
family. How are the kids?
-Amazing.
-Yeah?
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-And I have to tell you that my
son, Kameron, who is
13 years old,
is a big Jimmy Fallon fan,
which was really random for me
to find out on the way here.
-Really?
-I swear to God, I'm running
down what I have to do
in New York because
I'm very transparent
with my children.
I'm like,
"Okay, I have to do this.
I'll be back at this day."
He's like,
"So, what are you doing?"
I'm running down, I'm like,
"And 'Jimmy Fallon.'"
"What?! You're doing the --
That's really big, Mommy!"
He's like,
"I get his notifications.
I watch his YouTube."
-Really?
-I swear. He's a big fan.
-What's his name?
-Kameron Carter.
-Kameron! Kameron Carter,
you are a cool dude,
and you have the best taste
in late-night comedians.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love you, Kameron.
I love you, Kameron!
-We love you!
And Kross, and Kross.
-Yeah. And be cool.
We're cool, we're cool.
Let's talk about your new film,
"You People," which is so funny.
And you are just a breakout
in this.
-Oh, thank you.
-You can't take your eyes off
you in this.
You're fantastic.
-Thank you.
-Congrats. We had Kenya Barris
on the show,
who wrote and directed it.
And he's like, "Dude, get ready.
Watch Lauren.
She's going to pop
like Julia Roberts."
-That's a lot of pressure.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, he said he had to beg
you to do the movie.
Is that true?
-He didn't have to beg me.
But I wasn't sure if this was
aligned with
where I was going work-wise.
And I just wanted to make sure
that yes, this story had --
It was a brilliant script
and it was extremely funny.
But that the story had -- there
was more to be told than just
the comedy and I wanted to make
sure that the soul was in there.
-Yeah.
-And so those were my concerns.
-You got the comedy handled.
I mean, you got Eddie Murphy.
-Yeah, it's funny.
But we got to have some --
like, there were some questions
I had as far as
Jonah's character
and my character
and why they would naturally
connect.
And it had to be more than that
they're written in the script
and it's funny, but that they
were really friends first and --
-They liked hanging out
with each other.
-Yeah, and they had
a genuine connection.
-I was going to say, there's
some genuine moments
and you felt that chemistry.
-Yeah.
-Did you know Jonah
before this movie?
-I did not know Jonah
before this movie.
-He's great.
-Jonah is really my homeboy
in real life.
Like, I love me some Jonah Hill.
-Right?
-And when we first met,
we met like --
I think we had a meeting
like a couple --
like a couple weeks
before we shot.
And there was this big-ass --
ooh, big --
[ Laughter ]
-Kameron, turn the channel.
-He knows.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, okay, he had this big van
parked in the valet.
And I'm, like, trying to get in.
I'm honking like,
"Who is blocking the --"
And he comes out.
And he's like, "I'm so --
I think I'm supposed to meet you
today?"
I'm like, "Oh, you are.
How you doing?"
[ Laughter ]
-That's how you met?
-That's how we met.
-That's perfect. That's perfect.
Kind of goes with the movie too.
-It kind of --
Right, I was doing a lot.
-'Cause there's fun friend
energy.
And then you go, "Oh, these guys
are going to fall in love."
And it's good. No, I totally
felt it and got it.
Yeah, I'm a sucker for any of
those, like, rom-com things.
-Yeah, it's about time we have
another one.
-Yeah. It's great.
But then Julia Louis-Dreyfus.
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-She is one of the most giving
and caring scene partners ever.
-Really?
-She was just so welcoming
to me.
Because I was, like,
a little intimidated.
I'm like, "Oh, my God,
how am I going to improv
with these, like,
comedic giants?"
-Yeah.
-And she was just so open
and encouraging and just played
with me and opened up the space.
Ah, I love her.
-How do we set up the movie
and who you play?
-How do we --
I know Kenya set it up
real good when he came, huh?
-Oh, yeah.
-I can't do it as good as him.
So this is what I'll say.
Do I need to look somewhere?
-No.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Y'all, this is my first time.
-No, no, no, no.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're crushing it.
You are crushing it.
You are crushing it right now.
-Okay.
-I can help you with this.
This is my job.
I can help you.
-Okay, okay. Help me out.
Okay, so, I guess you would say
I play [Laughs] a girl
from L.A., Inglewood.
Comes from a Muslim family
that meets a nice white boy,
Jewish white boy from Brentwood.
-Yeah. Exactly, that's good.
-And we connect.
We fall in love.
And our families aren't so open
to what we have going on.
And so it's just --
-You can't control your family.
-No. No.
-No.
We wish we could in real life,
right?
-Yeah, you can't.
No, exactly right.
But it's great and it's funny.
I think the scene
we're going to show is
the first time
you guys actually meet.
He hops into your car thinking
that you're his Uber driver.
Here we go,
this is Lauren London
and Jonah Hill in "You People."
Take a look at this.
-[ Screams ]
Help, I'm being attacked!
-You're attacking me!
-Get out! Get out!
-Stop, stop! Please! Relax!
Fine, okay!
But you're not getting
five stars!
-I'm not an Uber driver.
-You're not?
-No, I'm not.
I'm on my way to work, weirdo.
-I am so sorry.
-No, you're not.
You saw a Black woman in an
inexpensive car and thought it
was your God-given white right
to get in my backseat
and tell me where to go.
Get out!
-I know this seems
like a racism.
-[ Scoffs ]
-But it's not.
My -- My Uber driver is a Black
woman who drives a mini Cooper.
Her name is Hyacinth Ajanlekoko.
-Oh, wow. Okay.
-Butatembe. So...
-So I guess Hyacinth whatever
looks like me
since we all look alike.
-I mean, honestly,
you guys are twins.
-Oh, my God, wait, she really
does look like me.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Lauren London, everybody.
"You People" is
in select theaters now.
It premieres on Netflix
this Friday.